hello rejects I'm Greg didn't need us
Anita um I'm doing that thing where
people go this person recommended this
video and I put there to accommodate oh
my god it's such a good thing this yeah
good the mix interactive is Right an
activity you guys isn't suddenly I'm
like oh my god it's so personal
see we're connecting overwatch Pro said
please react to the song chicken attack
that's amazing all right check this out
and you said and always keep up the
great video ah yes
these categorize is great great thinking
the video that we're watching out there
the great is in the channel um
Shmuel yo ho ho yo ho have about two and
a half million less subs than make you
so they're in the negative word I mean
there was a negative thing happening on
YouTube recently so not know lovely
algorithm Japanese real type it come
when I go go go through the waiting
already guys what does he talk you
should know that them how is the power
of nature accompany me to the end
and you should already
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
my uvula is like for miss winters you
want us to see
ha ha ha prepare oh my god
Houdini the ginko go for me Mikey come
on account this I use look
[Music]
they're fine
[Music]
shake it a Shack breaks off the kicking
you driving on them and hitting that
like button on your stone yeah we're
gonna be in the meantime check out
trump's inauguration thanks for watching
don't forget to bridge a chicken today
oh so they're like funny song they're
like Lonely Island but little different
yes sirree you think that man actually
was the singer
I wonder he could have been as
hysterical his voice has so said deep
Japanese voice and what he's saying is
not beautiful is this man is like
yodeling and I'm gonna download this
song now I'm just gonna my new favorite
song has to be that was really cool cuz
it like the way it was shot with like a
real Japanese movie and with the chicken
of Phegley turn on we check it out I
feel really cool like those lateral
chicken ninja chicken and you're ready
to the beating some it's actually a
pretty cool character do they say you
can control all animal yeah it's funny
cuz chicken yeah chicken is the best
chicken is the funny one but how cool
would that be with any animal that's
actually like a cool carrot and okay
okay control all animals turn to some
type of warrior that's that's pretty
cool idea for like a silly video they
actually the cinematography was Grace's
main Japanese do it's terrible poor
thing I would have wanted a little bit
more
like slightly cooler fighting but yeah I
can do with that I get thought about
that right it's more about you know the
chicken and the bad you know it's like
less about the actual fighting but it
would be nice to see some crazy like
just cutscene come through no music just
to chicken go and cream would be cool
or ever like to see if there's just a
chicken fighting you know there was like
a with the guys and Family Guy Peter
Griffin would be nice to see them just
like cut to them oh yeah before make
funny chicken fighting that meeting
Peters a good idea a good idea yeah the
song was hysterical so much more you can
really say about this letter than
[ __ ] kouddous man that was one out of
hilarious video yeah mo Yoho even made
like the the main guy a character who
has like a little our ski doesn't kill
the gut yeah gives him the chicken to me
to last another gentle here's with the
chicken fries yeah becomes a tree turns
into a badass really gone yeah
alright guys will subscribe to Schmo
Yoho guys Jews I know you can subscribe
to us subscribe to the real reject I
need a car star charge our our lard
well got a lard I need a large I have
large there's love really your al-'ardi
girl no party girl Marty woman you like
large again like Lauren check out this
one how much like shut up to the men
over watch pro over watch prowl dude
you're not over watching nothing yeah
you're just giving the right
recommendation no overwatch your game
no it's not I wouldn't know them I'm a
pure gamer anyone who watches this
channel never watching over watch Pro is
not a game okay you're thinking of Sonic
the Hedgehog you're right sorry you're
thinking I'm having Super Mario Brothers
ain't no game called overwatch what
character is they're called overwatch
maybe you're gonna confuse a halo one
night where you play a halo it'd be yeah
yeah your halo when you're playing
Reaper while you're playing overwatch
no yeah we're talking about